malgré une décision défavorable donc
annexe charette a tenu à s'exprimer à sa
sortie du tribunal
nous lui avons donné la parole même si
nous respectons la décision d'un juge
pour qu'elle témoigne de son parcours
dans le système judiciaire
nous avons rencontré juste après le
jugement je vais d'abord demandé à chaud
comment elle se sentait je me sens
impuissante impuissante face en direct
de droit des procédures des procédés qui
répondent aux codes de la justice ne
correspond pas nécessairement à l'équité
la justice intrinsèque
ça dépend des codes de droit gilbert
rozon a donc été acquitté
mais la juge hébert précise que ça
signifie pas que les événements ne se
sont pas produits comment vous recevez
cette déclaration mais on est ici dans
vraiment dans l'application des règles
de droit parce que il ya une procédure
un espèce de gris qui est apposé pour en
droit criminel sur le hors de tout doute
raisonnable
la couronne n'a pas établi cette preview
taux raisonnables mais comment peut-elle
l'établir dans un cas ou deux versions
contradictoires sont mis l'une vers
l'autre et la juge dispose d'atouts le
pendant tout son énoncé quand même dit à
plusieurs reprises que ce soit que
c'était une équitable que les accusés
parce que le droit était ce fip c'est
correct puisque le droit suisse fait on
beaucoup plus de place et beaucoup plus
de poids dans la machine judiciaire que
peuvent avoir les
les victimes comme moi à payer parce
c'est inéquitable et oui c'est
inéquitable cette inéquité la csu
interpelle parce que c'est pas comme
dans un procès où tu as eu des preuves
matérielles outre le procès qui oppose
deux versions pourquoi une des versions
aurait tout cet espace mais sur usine23
trois ans pour étudier ma version
construire des contre eux une contrée
version être conseillés par ses avocats
deux avocats de mérite avec une équipe
de recherchistes
on pourrait parler de justice des riches
on voulait venir mais moi j'ai été
témoigné une fois devant la police puis
trois ans plus tard devant la cour à
froid bac bing moi ce soit la preuve
raisonnable que la cour devait faire
c'est ça c'est mon témoignage
on dit qui est crédible dont 10 qui est
solide mais semble se passer pour donner
à mener une condamnation c'est les
règles de la cause directe de droits
d'édition pour vous décevant wii 2
seulement pour moi mais pour toutes les
victimes d'agressions sexuelles aussi
parce que autant les gens ont dit la
qualité de mon témoignage
la montagne est haute c'est le mien pas
suffi à ramener à ce qu'est ce qui
suffira mais on doit pas baisser les
bras parce que le droit précède jamais
la société la société qui change le
droit si notre société juge que ceci
n'est pas équitable ou n'est pas valable
c'est la société qui doit se mettre en
oeuvre pour changer ça le juge dit il
subsiste un doute raisonnable sur la
culpabilité de monsieur rozon qu'est-ce
qui a été le plus difficile dans ce
procès pour vous l'impuissance encore
une fois pas nécessairement du goût du
résultat mais d'actes racistes dans une
salle à écouter ce procès se passer
alors que on est en dehors on est je
sais pas si les gens se rendent compte
en impression que ces deux comme au
civil que on oppose non moi c'est le
procureur qui parle pour la société il
ya la défense qui parle pour l'accusé et
la victime c'est un témoin elles n'ont
ni représentation ni droit de parole
uniquement de témoigner ne peut pas se
lever pour ben voyons moi j'étais au
courant de la version de me suis roseaux
in-situ au procès et comment ça va finir
avant la fin de mon témoignage l'avocate
n'a posé la question et moi si je vous
disais que c'est monsieur rozon que vous
avez agressé monsieur aux autres j'ai
juste j'étais de déconcerter d'après
fois j'entendais ça j'étais comme magog
on m'a jamais demandé c'est mon avis sur
cette chose le nom me le demande le au
milieu d'une cour puis cinq minutes j'ai
été me rasseoir c'est tout mais c'était
c'est sa version des faits oui je ne
vais pas appeler j'ai appris en cours et
comment vous vous êtes senti à cette
version des faits est déconcertée étonné
savez aucun sens pour moi ça n'avait
aucun sens que je vais en fait ma
première réaction a été de sourire parce
que je trouve ça complètement farfelu
mais semble-t-il que ça pouvait ne pas
être fait lui mais je voudrais valait la
peine
oui il faut le faire moi ce que ce n'est
que le début de mon implication
il faut le faire parce que c'est la
seule façon qu'on va pousser la société
évolue et il faut que des victimes
dénoncent sinon donne toute la place aux
agresseurs il faut que les victimes se
relève et continue de dénoncer malgré
tout malgré les échecs malgré sa fougue
en soit forte
puis moi le sait ce que c'est là moi je
me mets en marche partir d'aujourd'hui
là dessus ça sera mon combat personnel
que ce cas les victimes d'agression
sexuelle peut se trouver un écho dans le
système judiciaire mais un écho dans
d'autres systèmes aussi parce qu'il n'ya
pas juste le système judiciaire pour
venir à bout 2 il était rapide la
médiation de la justice réparatrice
il ya plein d'options qu'avec mis sur la
table un tribunal spécialisé il faut que
les intervenants soient formés parce que
ça c'est une chose aussi que dans les
victimes se plaignent beaucoup le
premier accueil mouassa pas été mon cas
ça a été fabuleux
les inspecteurs ont été d'une telle
bienveillance mon égard c'est quand même
mais il faut qu'on soit j'avais été
accompagnés dès le début par des gens
comme chez jury pas pour les cavac bien
tête des choses que j'aurais d'une
meilleure façon
d'autres choses mais deux mers façon qui
aurait peut-être été
performante parce que c'est ça qu'on
nous demande c'est incroyable une
victime pour soit performante c'est pas
performante c'est fini
moi ce que je veux leur appareil sorti
ce matin il se veut d'un groupe
d'experts dont qui a rendu public son
rapport aujourd'hui est justement parmi
les recommandations il y aurait les
tribunaux spécialisés pour les
agressions sexuelles est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça ce que c'est une
bonne chose mais ces tribunaux
spécialisés agissent selon les mêmes
règles de droit qui nous ont prévalu
aujourd'hui je sais pas quel peut être
le résultat mais il faut continuer faut
se battre
faut être là pour les victimes dénoncent
le g n'est fait de mon action il
appartient en fait parce qu'en rompant
le silence
j'ai déposé mon fardeau c'est un fort
doute support à l'intérieur de toi
c'est quelque chose que tu j'ai des
crises à quelqu'un d'autre comme étant
des cicatrices intérieur parfois tu
t'accroches les doigts dedans cette
année terre de toi tu t'accroches les
doigts dans ce cas oui ça fait encore
remarquer non on ne touche pas aux
fondements maintenant je pars de touche
et c'est tant mieux je touche le set
avec cette cicatrice loge qu'elle a
montré tout le monde maintenant
et puis à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur
est ce que vous êtes prête à tourner la
page
face à cette étonnante cet événement
alors oui oui c'est fait c'est fait à
partir d'aujourd'hui je sais ce qu'est
ce que vous voulez que je fasse de moi
j'ai fait ce que j'avais à faire
j'ai été jusqu'au bout j'étais digue
marche penses tu peux rien faire d'autre
ce que je peux faire c'est pour les
autres victimes je vais le faire
d'ailleurs je veux la collaboration à
qui en veut bien au ministère où
n'importe qui parce que vivre cette
expérience de l'intérieur ça vaut la
peine d'être mises sont que ce soit et
non c'est tout ce qu'on peut traverser
où on se dit je laisse faire ça
autrement c'est pas seulement pendant 40
ans à chaque fois je pense que j'avais
honte je me fais une débat j'aurais pas
dû rester le sémaphore c'est ma faute
ces foules vous disiez ça oui parce que
je résume débat je rêve sortir j'aurais
dû partir j'aurais dû j'aurais donc dû
paraître lourd c'est sûr qu'on se met
sur les treize donner sa voix comme un
instrument de la même chose
mais maintenant que j'ai le plus beau
jeu sont plus coupables de vue que les
autres sachent que c'est entre eux que
le bénéfice de sa et si vous vous sentez
comme ça moi je vous tende la main que
je vous ai débat ce qu'on mérite pas son
mérite dans le monde sans harcèlement et
sans violence je parle pour les femmes
et je parle pour les hommes c'est pas
que les femmes qui sont concernés par
une charrette merci beaucoup merci c'est
une gueule